is buying a 2 000 or 10 000 course the
way to uh
become an entrepreneur it's it's
definitely not
it's definitely not like all the people
i know or successful
entrepreneurs are not selling courses on
entrepreneurship
successful entrepreneurs because they
have some business that's working and
they're
mostly just doing that if the if they're
selling courses then you are the
business
justin obviously everyone wants to know
what happened to dr disrespect
everyone's dying to know
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
coffeezilla another edition of sunday
special where we talk about whatever the
hell i want today we have a
very very special guest we have justin
khan he's the founder of
twitch.justin.tv which eventually became
twitch.tv which he co-founded with
emmett shearer michael siebel and kyle
vogt
you eventually sold twitch for almost a
billion dollars to amazon
you've started several companies since
like a socialcam atrium and you've been
an investor in
a y combinator and you now have your own
seed company called goat capital
so all of this is to say justin
sincerely i have no idea why you decided
to come on
the show today to my little channel but
i really appreciate you taking the time
thanks for having me i came on because i
watched the
interview you did with my friend jason
calcionis and i
thought it was funny i loved it so and
plus i i
respect the mission which is to expose
all this you know
the internet fraudsters and uh
and flush them out that's the main
reason
i wanted to bring you on because there
are just this huge
influx of entrepreneurs selling success
on the internet
and i think everyone knows the type
they're doing stuff you know you
probably never heard of any companies
they built but they're talking like you
know
they're god's gift to entrepreneurs and
they're selling success
overnight success in a 2 000 course i've
been ranting
about what a scam this is for a long
time but getting jason on was so great
getting you on so great because i want
to talk to real entrepreneurs
who have really done it because um you
guys are the people
that people need to be listening to as
far as um getting advice and you're not
gonna you're not gonna
try to sell them success because you
guys know that's ridiculous but let me
just ask for the sake of it
is buying a 2 000 or thousand dollar
course the way to uh beca
become an entrepreneur i mean it's it's
definitely not
it's definitely not like the thing that
always strikes me
if these people are successful all the
people i know who are successful are
entrepreneurs
are not selling courses on
entrepreneurship
they're they're successful entrepreneurs
because they have some business that's
working
and they're mostly just doing that like
if
if they're selling courses then you are
the business
like you are the you're you're the one
who's getting farmed
here and so i just like white combinator
being a great example you know i spent
years at y combinator
yc was the investor in twitch
or justin tv the company that triggered
twitch wesley's also
first investor in airbnb dropbox reddit
coinbase instacart and tons and tons of
other startups thousands of other
startups now
for the last 15 years and yc
does all of its content for free
right all of the content out there on
youtube on podcasts
it's all free all the essays that paul
graham started writing and then all the
other white supporters write
and that i wrote when i was at yc are
free
why why does it that's a cost center
right like why do people spend their
time doing doing that because it's the
funnel for the actual business
the actual business is investing in
companies right some of those companies
become airbnb
and then everybody makes a [ __ ] a ton of
money like that's how the business works
not monetizing the audience of hopeful
entrepreneurs
which not only would be a much worse
business than
you know actually what yc does today but
it's also we view it as like much less
ethical right like the the point of it's
almost anti-encouraging people if you're
if you're monetizing them in a way
that's exploited
yeah because it seems like when you're
early stage i mean you are
working on limited funds and so if
you're all of a sudden going to give ten
thousand dollars away to some
business coach there's there's almost no
way they're going to provide that much
value as it
they could take like a percent a point a
few points of your company
and then advise you that's what a lot of
legitimate entrepreneurs do or you know
you have companies like y combinator
instead they go no we want an upfront
fee and that's i think
the most telling thing is you take
people who are like hopefuls
and you do it but um i don't think
people understand how big the industry
is i've been railing about
it for like a year year and a half and
uh it's
it's a billion dollar industry all these
guys basically
selling success um
what would you say to someone who's like
sort of stuck in that loop
and doesn't know how to differentiate
some real advice
because a lot of these guys give a lot
of like kind of a boilerplate advice
they say like work really hard
you know uh save your money all that
kind of stuff how would you
differentiate
it's all well so i i think there's a
question of like the
the source which the source is coming
from actually i want to give you one
more example from y combinator unlike
what somebody who you know an
organization that's
pro founder looks like versus one that's
maybe
kind of anti-founder anti-entrepreneur
and so
with yc one of our biggest expenses when
i was at y company i don't know if this
is still true especially during the
pandemic but we used to fly
in entrepreneurs to interview with us
for a 10-minute interview to see who we
would find would
they would come in from all over the
world all over the country and all over
the world
and we would pay for it because we
didn't want people to go out of pocket
to do an interview for us so
yc's biggest expense was to pay for
hundreds of people every six months to
fly in from like
sometimes it was like from africa or
india or whatever so they could meet us
so we could decide whether we wanted to
fund them or not and
that you know we didn't have to do that
people would have gladly paid themselves
but it wasn't the ethos who were saying
we don't entrepreneurs who are starting
off
don't have a lot of money so it's our
duty
our you know ethical duty to try to be
as supportive as possible and since we
are in this position of relative power
and
are making very decent money
like we should pay for this and so you
know that we would throw events we threw
like
conferences for thousands of people and
they would entirely be free it wouldn't
be
you don't even have to pay you know any
amount it would be like
completely free and we would you know do
it entirely from an application basis
you know and so
i think there there's that's the
difference between
a firm that's really trying to organize
around helping entrepreneurs versus
somebody who's trying to monetize and
exploit potential entrepreneurs
sorry that wasn't answering your
question but your your actual question
was how do you determine
fake you know or like good advice from
from
maybe more generic advice i mean i would
look at who is giving this advice right
i think that's really important and what
i mean by that is like
the people i know who are like the best
entrepreneurs
are not that flashy
they're not out there on social media
posting pictures of their
you know lamborghini like they're
they're just not like i don't know a
single entrepreneur who's like a
successful tech entrepreneur in silicon
valley they might own a life
like a lot of them own a lamborghini but
almost none of them are posting pictures
of it
saying they're going to teach you how to
be wealthy enough to buy that whenever
none of them are it's so it's so
unbelievable
unbelievably tacky um and it's become
that way sort of because so many of
these sort of lifestyle people who you
know don't really have it
have been renting them and they've sort
of i think i honestly think they've
devalued a lot of the brand of
um lamborghini and it's sort of made it
like oh if you want to sort of show you
have wealth you don't get a lamborghini
you get something maybe a little
more exotic that it's sort of like if
you know you know kind of cars there's a
lot of that
um yeah yeah to go back to your point
about you know even like
why commenter would pay out of pocket to
find good talent i mean that you can
find the same thing in a lot of um
you know trading is another big thing
where they sell a lot of courses but
there's also
legitimate like you know institutional
funds where they'll pay you it's called
an internship
to learn they know you're not like
qualified to go make them a ton of money
right now but they want to invest
knowing that maybe 10 of those interns
will turn into
future traders of theirs right and so i
think that is a great rule of thumb is
like
where are they taking their value in the
lifespan of you as
you know as a customer are they taking
their or an employee are they taking
their value
at the beginning of the value chain you
know before you've done anything
or are they taking it sort of in the
future when you've proven yourself
and that shows whether they're really
betting on you right or they're betting
on just like a huge number of people
coming in
um and just sort of making money money
at the top of the funnel
it seems like that's exactly right you
know it's kind of like angel investors
who are
there's some angel investors that are
paid a pitch you know and that's like a
[ __ ] scam
like when people make you pay to pitch
like they're they're if you're a real
investor your business is on finding
amazing investments
and a pay to pitch is an adverse
selection right because like someone
who's good is not going to do that
and so you know it's just that's an
example have you figured out about the
clubhouse grift yet
i mean that's a whole thing that's going
on right now there's so many of these
me and jason have been going off about
it at him more than i i mean he's like
he like really sees it as you know
his worst enemy are some of these guys
on clubhouse having people pitch to them
and then they'll take these investors
sometimes it won't be paid a pitch but
it'll be like
hey yeah give us 30 of your company for
coaching
and it's like what 30 30 and no value
like it's a revenue generating company
they'll give us 30 percent it's just
absolutely
insane but i think part of the problem
is so um
silicon valley captures the best talent
in the world but then you sort of have
like you have people that y combinator
accepts
and then you have people sort of who are
able to get into y combinator but they
still
want uh sort of what you might call
entrepreneur help which is a really
valuable thing
what would you tell companies who aren't
lucky enough or fortunate enough to get
into y combinator
who were looking for that kind of
helping hand and now they have a bunch
of grifters promising them
you know come with me i'll give you
success how can those people
get that help that they want without
falling for these
yeah so i think that's really tough
right because the best
like there's there's like a little bit
of a like kind of global
network effect where the best talent
like the best advisors
investors etc are like looking for the
best companies because they want that
facebook or uber airbnb like return
and so it makes sense but i mean but the
access to that
mentorship is like very limited right
like i probably look at
a thousands like a thousand companies a
year and like i might
find fund 20 of them right or 30 of them
so that's like two percent or three
percent and so
you know i just don't have the time
right like i'm just one guy of course
and so
you know that's kind of the way it is
for for
all of the you know successful
entrepreneurs and investors in silicon
valley and understandably other people
want
mentorship and they want to figure out
how they um
can find people you know mentors and and
i think that
then they get fooled i guess by these
these kind of people who look they come
in like the clothing of a mentor right
but they're like not
you know or like yeah what people think
they should look like with the with the
lambo and
uh you know a million instagram
followers or whatever
and then you get fooled by it but you
know that doesn't
exist i guess like part of i mean this
is not a very
maybe this isn't like easiest message to
hear but it's like
part of what you have to do as an
entrepreneur is you know kind of
get to the stage prove yourself to get
to a stage where
people who are successful want to help
you and want to like
work with you and usually that requires
some
level of evidence on your part so why
see it might be like
you know you don't have to be a
successful company yet but you have to
be able to build a product
right you have to demonstrate that you
can build a product and that that's hard
because like a lot of people are like
well
i don't know how to build a product and
i don't know how to
you know successfully find a technical
co-founder you know if they're not
technical or
and so you know we couldn't really help
those people and a lot of them still
wanted something but like you know it
was just kind of like
burns on you to go and get to that proof
point and then once you get funded by yc
there's another
milestone which okay you want to raise a
series a from like real investors
you need to really prove some set of
milestones in terms of growing that
product and trying to get there
and you know that's just kind of the way
the world works it's like
if you want people to help you the best
way to do that is to help yourself and
to get
to kind of show that you're worth
helping
and um all the information the positive
thing i can probably
is that all the information to to figure
that out is out there for free like all
the most
successful people in the world not just
silicon valley have put this information
out there like how to raise money
how to build a product how to find
product product market fit it's all free
yeah out there
you could read it like i put a video out
on youtube on my channel
that's like how to pitch investors and
how to raise money from investors how to
create a narrative around that right
put that out there for free because
i just want to get that information out
there it's like people helped me when i
with the same type of stuff when i was
coming up and so it's my joy to help
entrepreneurs in that way
it's not i don't need to like lock it
behind a paywall because i know if i put
enough good karma out there with my
content then i'm gonna get a lot of
entrepreneurs who are like oh i want to
work with you
and you know my job is to select the
best of those who will provide the best
returns
100 there are no secrets this is what i
keep trying to tell people and um
it's so great to hear it from somebody
who's you know
been there done that and it seems like
it's all execution then right because if
the information's out there
then what ch what changes the variable
the x
is execution and learning how to nail
that execution how to like meet the
right people
at the right time um something that
strikes me
is that you and your co-founders i mean
you guys are all like crushing it
your co-founders are now like emmitt
shears
i think the ceo of twitch right michael
siebel managing director of y combinator
kyle vogt is the uh ceo of cruz
um so you know and you guys were like
hanging around steve huffman at the time
co-founder of reddit
it seems to me like okay there's no
coincidence that all these people sort
of surrounding each other hanging around
all ended up doing great things it seems
like network
you guys just had a great network how do
how much of your success do you
contribute to your network and how do
you build a great network
yeah that's a great question and it
applies to everybody right
that's why i love that question it's
like the interesting thing is the
success didn't really come
from the like you might see the later
stage network and be like oh he's
friends with the ceos of
reddit and coinbase and you know all
these other companies
and you know that may be why he was able
to become successful but
it was actually like in the beginning we
were all just
nobodies that's what i'm saying no no
that's what i'm saying it's like these
people who seem to be hanging out early
on
all went and like started a lot of the
companies we all know today
but it's just funny to me because i was
watching some of your videos about like
you were like out partying with steve
huffman and i'm like how funny is it
that the guy like
who co-founded twitch is also hanging
out with the guy who co-founded reddit
i mean it doesn't to me that doesn't
seem like coincidence there's a lot of
smart people out in the world
but there's a there's obviously
something happening here if two people
so close together co-founded some of the
like biggest companies or internet
companies ever
yeah it's not a coincidence right
because people group together like if
you want to be
there's this old adage that's like
you're the average of your five best
friends
so if you want to be an actor then you
should go make friends with people who
are
trying to be an actor actors or or are
actors if you want to be an entrepreneur
you want to make friends with people who
want to be entrepreneurs or are
entrepreneurs and surround yourself with
that and that's one of the
really powerful things about y
combinators it's a community of
entrepreneurs where entrepreneurship was
previously a very solo journey right
like it's something that's very isolated
kind of like you're figuring out by
yourself
and so what i come into this community
of entrepreneurs and it brought together
a lot of these early
founders of internet companies in this
kind of 2005
starting a 2005 wave and uh
you know it was just self-selecting like
people like i wouldn't be
wanted to be an entrepreneur so i kind
of became in this community i joined
this community and i
got funded by ycn and i became friends
with all these people in ycn
that was my friend group and you know
today those people
have become successful because it turns
out like any form of success
you know you start working on it and
then 10 years later or 15 years later
like that's when it really pays off and
so
um you know all these people were just
kind of smart you know relatively smart
but but mostly people would
opted in to working on internet startups
and were working hard 10 years ago and
then
became something now you know because
because of that hard work they put in
how do you find that network if you
don't have something sort of
ready made like y combinator you know is
such a
um cool thing for so many entrepreneurs
what would you say to somebody who's
living in like
illinois or the uk or india maybe they
don't have
such like a startup scene right in their
local area or a scene for whatever they
want
um is it possible to create your own
scene
what would you tell people yeah that's a
great question because
it is like a lot of these networks now
have moved online and are
much more accessible to people who are
anywhere in the world yeah so
some examples like why combinatories
itself anyone can apply to y commander
from anywhere in the world
there's companies that are like african
solar companies that have been funded by
yc or like
indonesian you know delivery companies
like companies like
everywhere in the world really and so um
that community is online and we can
apply
for free right like so you can just
apply for free now not everyone can get
in because yc only funds a limited
number of companies but you can
you know you can apply but then there's
all these other digital
communities of people who are building
things um like for example i'm
i'm in this one called gen z mafia
although
probably shouldn't tell them because i'm
definitely not gen z i'm old as [ __ ]
but like these what i love about this
it's it's all these gen z kids who are
building
stuff it's kind of like startup uh gen z
and they're on the discord server and
that as far as i know is free i think
maybe anyone can join it or there's
maybe an application process but
um that's a great community where where
all these people are
trading tips about startups and talking
about startup news and doing doing
fireside chats with people from silicon
valley and like
it's a great network you know i've hired
people out of that server then i you
know they asked me to come in for a chat
and then i've hired people out of server
not funding companies from that server
so
you know that's an easy way to get
access to somebody like me and i know
there's many other
successful entrepreneurs and with you
know investors who have talked
spoken on that server it is and i want
to dive deep i didn't know we were going
to talk about this but it just sparks
such an
interesting conversation for me about
like networking and i find it so
fascinating
so many times you get in these
communities and you might like feel like
a bit of an
outsider or the conversations you're
having with people are purely
um sort of transactional how do you turn
what is just sort of we just hang out in
the same
discord server into something that's
like
hey we're actually maybe interested in
helping each other
um maybe with a business venture
or whatever how do you break down that
wall of like hey justin khan's in this
discord server obviously
that's like cool but he doesn't know me
i don't know him
um you know the internet has
democratized you know
talking to like celebrities to
interesting people but so often they
have like sort of that walled garden how
do you break past who's
how do how have people in the past
broken past with you
yeah so so i think there's a couple
questions in there one is like specific
to me and then the other one i hear is
how do you build these relationships in
general like so starting with the
generalized case
like people do business with people
right and if you just
build a real relationship with with
somebody then
you have their they become a resource to
you
right it's like they're like a social
resource right it's like social capital
and it's interesting because people
don't
think about that as that much but it's
just like you just need to build
work on your relationships and that's
what ultimately is going to pay off in
business like
for me it's like i have i've been
someone who loves connecting with people
and i've always wanted to connect with
people
and i connect with people try to meet
them and know them
long before that there's ever some
useful thing that i want from them or
want to do with them
business-wise you know i'm an investor
in reddit you know i let him
participate in investment in reddit and
that was years ago i knew steve for
for over you know 12 years before
even that that was on the table and it
just happened because you know we were
friends and he was commiserating on
how he wanted to raise some money and i
was like okay you know maybe i can help
you with that
and so you know that kind of came out of
a friendship right
and so i think there's there's an
example of there's a lot of
examples for me in my life about you
know really just
worrying about developing relationships
first and then eventually
something economic can can grow from
that um
and then you know in terms of like the
general question of like
well sorry that was the general answer
the specific question of like how do you
how do you get in touch with me well you
know i've answered
dms from people on that discord server
where they're like oh how do i
think about you know this approaching
this that start a problem or
you know and i i'm pretty accessible
like people i read my twitter and
instagram dms
largely and people will send me messages
and the things that work
are it's the same as cold email it's
like
someone like me i think i'm a little bit
more accessible maybe than most people
who are
maybe have done you know start a billion
dollar company but um
i like to help people and i generally
talk to people who are i'm willing to
respond
when things are made easy for me so it's
like it's there's a concrete
ask it's not too long like you're not
sending like a 10 paragraph email it's
like
here's the context for why you might
want to be interested in me like what
i'm working on etc
here's like my specific question or ask
and then
thank you that's it boom like you know
five sentences
and that's like this you know it's kind
of table stakes and then there's
you know people it helps when you're
asking something that's like
i get something out of it right like
yeah and what i mean by it's not i'm
getting something like i'm getting
money or status or something like that
but like maybe i'm learning something
right like
you can teach me something that's really
interesting if you ask me like someone
was i was chatting with someone random
today
and he was asking like this conversation
kind of started with like
you know i'm kind of struggling with
with a bunch of things and like i just
wanted your advice on these things i'm
struggling with
and that's like interesting it's like oh
by helping you i actually feel good
about myself i'm getting something right
then there was like it pivoted to like
can you give me advice on my y
combinator application
then i'm like no longer really getting
anything because it's like well you
could read that i
think i've written about it there's a
lot of stuff online it's like so
i'm like not i'm you know i'm doing
probably i probably
i'm going to be on zoom today for like
11 hours so like that became the prior
to this right like i would like to help
everyone if i could but i just that was
no longer super interesting to me
and so you know it's just think about
that like put yourself in the
like so many people who come and reach
out if don't put themselves in the
context
yeah the person they're reaching out to
yes correct so
so just imagine you're me and i get
probably like
50 100 dms or message emails
or whatever a day that's not even
including pick doc and youtube comments
or whatever right so like again
there's a ton of reach out today how can
you
contextualize the thing that you want in
a way that
is giving me something back even if it's
just learning
oh i totally get it no i don't think
you're being it doesn't come across as
like selfish at all that's just how
people
are they want to contextualize in a way
that fits fits into their life fits into
their goals it could be even like
you have a mission to help xyz
contextualize it within
what you you care about as well i do
find that people who have been
successful um
very non-pretentious and a lot of them
want to give back they feel like a debt
to you know to to give back to people i
find that all the time which is why it's
so funny to me
that you know you have people charging
twenty thousand dollars for
an hour coaching call and it's like
they're nobo i mean they're just a
nobody and it's like they're charging so
much money for
this thing and it's it's just um crazy
now i want to pivot a little bit
and talk about some of the paradoxes in
entrepreneurship
um which is something that we talked
about like general advice
and how it's sometimes useful but
sometimes it's not the right use case so
persistence is a common trait for
entrepreneurs that they need to have it
to get through sort of the valley of
non-adoption that nobody cares about
your product yet right
um but on the other hand
most ideas will not work and if you can
kind of cut your losses early if you can
find out your idea is not going to work
it kind of it's good in a certain kind
of way you even said this in a recent
ama you're like
i don't remember exactly i said it you
said like learn to
how to quit early it only gets harder
how do you
know the difference that seems like it's
paradoxical on the one hand
entrepreneurs should persist on the
other hand they should learn to
quit early when they realize their idea
is not going to work and they can start
something else
it's i think it's really hard to to tell
because there's no real formula
you know for it's kind of like when
people get give up
people give up when they run out of
ideas on how to make it work
and so the way that you want to
you know if you have some mission of
like something you want to bring into
the world
the key is that you like continually
have new ideas on how
to make it how you could bring that
about right
and usually what happens is
entrepreneurs run out of ideas they run
off things that
that that they could try and then they
give up from there
i don't have a formula i'm like when you
should give up you know it's it's
with twitch we pivoted multiple times we
had this show that was called justin tv
you know where we were trying to create
a live video stream and then that didn't
work so we turned it into
a platform for live video which worked
for a while which and then eventually
pivoted to twitch
so it's a very secure route um but one
thing i
i can say is if you don't want to give
up if you have this mission and you
don't want to give up then
you know the thing to do is surround
yourself with co-workers and co-founders
who can really support you on you know
and when you're feeling down they're
like maybe
charging ahead it's to like constantly
put yourself in positions where you can
think of new ideas for how to
how to kind of innovate and like iterate
to
towards something that works and the
last thing is really work on something
you really intrinsically care about
if you don't work on if you're not you
don't care about something then when you
it stops working outside it gets tough
that that's when
you're most likely to give up that's
such a great answer
i you know something i think about when
i you know as i'm talking to you
is that um you're someone who sort of
climbed the mountain achieved
whether you would say so or not you've
achieved the silicon valley dream
of the huge exit you have this even this
company co-founded also went on to
do great things like it didn't bomb it's
like it's doing incredible things
um what i mean no literally you're like
like
one of the fathers of modern gaming and
that being a legitimate career i mean
say that with like no exaggeration
seriously you've enabled and empowered
so many people who
you know never thought they'd have a
career in this it is amazing and that
is like the dream of you know social
like being able to change things
but i kind of am so interested in
you know people like yourself because
the question is like what now what
inspires you
what inspires justin today is it to
build another you know billion dollar
company
what gets you out of bed and gets you
excited
for like keep pushing keep pursuing
yeah that's a great question there's one
i wrestled with for a very long time
so for me i wanted to create a bigger
company you know i had friends who were
i had you know a billion dollar exit
with twitch but then we looked at
guys who were friends of mine who were
like brian chesky from airbnb or drew
from dropbox that they were like doing
way better so
for a long time i was highly motivated
to
you know because i was pursuing these
extrinsic goals right these egoic goals
to like be more successful and so i
tried
uh started this other company long story
short didn't work you know raised a lot
of money for it had high expectations
and then you know somewhere along the
way i realized like
actually you could never have lasting
satisfaction from pursuing external
goals
right and people always say when i say
that they're like oh it's easy for you
to say you already had you already made
it
it's like well okay i've been there yes
but i've also
looked at my friends who were more
successful and thought oh i want to be
there you know i want to be there
and they're probably pushing because
they want they're looking up too they're
like there's somebody above me with
a bigger more zeros by their name or
whatever by their net worth or doing
more
that's the human condition right this is
to always be looking
it's i did a post on this on my
podcast the quest but i'm going to put
it on youtube as well
it's called hedonic adaptation right or
the hedonic treadmill where
we get to a new place and then we're
like oh but what about this place
it becomes we could get adapted to it
and then it's just business as usual
when i was you know i could i i uh
some good examples of that like of like
of like hedonic adaptation in your life
yeah yeah exactly i'll give you the
example because it was interesting as an
entrepreneur i went through the entire
like every step so when we started off
in 2006
we paid ourselves like 1700 a month or
this is in 2005 with my first company
seventeen hundred dollars a month
every other month i skipped salary so we
paid ourselves basically like
eight hundred dollars a month and then
when we raised our first venture round
for justin tv we
got seventy five thousand dollar a month
a year salary and then from there
when we raised the next round i think we
boosted it to a hundred thousand
and then we became profitable at some
point so it was like 150
and then we got to some profitability
and we raised it to 200 000. this was
over the course of like
five years yeah and then we spun out a
company
first and we sold it for 60 million
dollars and so everybody got like a
pretty big taste you know like and we
became millionaires
and then we sold we sold twitch for 790
we started off i thought i said if we
could just make
a million dollars each in this business
that would be crazy you may be insane
you've made it yeah we would have made
it
yeah and we blew by that obviously and
so the funny thing was like i never got
any happier like every i every time i
made more money i was like oh this is
nice
for like one week and then that was like
my new normal now i'm the type of guy
who makes two hundred thousand dollars a
year
you know now i'm the type of guy who has
millions of dollars in spain that's it
and and so you know i can see that with
all my friends
they could be worth it's funny i just
had a friend he raised money in a
billion dollar evaluation
that was his dream life stream right and
then he's like looking he was telling me
he's like i'm looking at he's like i'm
friends with
brian from coinbase right they're going
to ipo for like whatever
they're they're kind of so he's like
he's like yeah
so he's he is upset
he's being upset yeah right and so
people don't believe it but hedonic
adaptation is is that
the truth of the human condition right
and so
i think that that is that's something
that that people
really don't realize and so for me you
know what what kept me going
at first was just like i want more more
more more
and then today to get back to the
original question
i really try to think about like what is
my intrinsic motivation
like what gives me joy like what do i
like to do what would i do for no
no money and if nobody was watching it's
this is it
it's the same it's like yeah yeah yeah
sorry go ahead yeah what do you love
so it's like it's like yeah and it
was like i love helping people and so i
like to
be an investor because it's an
opportunity to learn about new things
like learn
new businesses and new ideas and then
also help people
entrepreneurs with my pretty much my
only skill set which is like
entrepreneurship and then i love
creating and i love the creative process
of creating so that's why
i'm on youtube and tick tock and
whatever i'm it's like it's fun for me
it's it's messing around with
being creative and i that's how i've
tried to design my jobs like
can i get out of bed and do those things
that's if i can that's a successful day
if not then you know maybe i need to
iterate and adapt
some things i do sense that that's the
beating heart of
you know um of what you like to do
because even if you go back to the
origins of
justin.tv it's like hey let me
livestream my life which is such a
that's like a pretty artsy idea like
especially at the time
before you know before this was a normal
thing
um that's a real out-there art house
idea
that you wanted to do um which is why
like i love your story is because you
found a way to you know turn into this
awesome thing which uh ended up
empowering other people to pursue
their art which i think is so cool um
justin
you you have a youtube channel right and
i that's something huge i want to shout
out
is that you have a youtube channel where
you talk about entrepreneurship you talk
about
angel investing you talk about how you
got drunk with steve
huffman and got arrested i mean like
incredible
honestly when i saw your youtube channel
i was like this guy should have
millions and millions and millions of
subscribers i highly encourage everyone
to check it out
what can people expect in the future of
the the man who started live streaming
what's the future of that youtube
channel
i'm having so much fun with it it's uh
it's kind of crazy i did not think it
would be this fun um
originally i started because i wanted to
promote my podcast but like actually i
love my youtube channel in like a
completely different way
so it's content like i tell a lot of
silicon valley war stories like
the story of selling to google or almost
only to google twitch could have been
owned by google
and then walking away from the mega
monopoly would have been
would have been realized if you had sold
to google it would have all been real
trouble
yep so stuff like that i've been i tell
the story of um
you know like how we pivoted to twitch
from justin tv
i just like a long list of early
entrepreneurship stories and then
uh like a lot of how to's i'm gonna be
you know i did one on fundraising that's
like
kind of the most hyped how-to
fundraising video ever but like if
you're an entrepreneur you want to raise
money
um i want to do i think i'm going to
start making like vlog content just like
people are interested about you know
what's my day-to-day and
um so you know doing videos on like
just the random stuff that i get up to
and i don't know i'm just having fun
with it
that is awesome man i want to um go
ahead go ahead
i want to give people like an authentic
view into what my life is like because i
just
i think i have a pretty fun time trying
to be helpful
really focused on meditation and
wellness or some
things that are like really important to
me so my goal is really just to
give people a view into my life and what
silicon valley is like but then also
maybe teach some skills that might be
helpful to people for themselves down
the road
that is awesome man um people can go
check it out i want people to buy my
course
yeah yeah yeah you're you're uh your six
thousand dollar
life coaching justin khan course uh
to to get invited to pitch at y
combinator guys you gotta pay your way
in
i'm just kidding um then uh
justin obviously everyone wants to know
what happened to doctor disrespect
everyone's dying to know
getting um you know what's so funny it's
like i made a tick tock about
the act where i was like yeah every like
i made this tick tock
and the tick tock someone every time i
post on tick tock or whatever
or youtube people are like what about
doctor just what happened to doctors
respect what happened to this stream
what happened to the streamer why is
this streamer
still unbanned so it's either why did
you ban this person why did you unban
this person yeah
and then the funny thing is so i
uh i posted i was like okay finally like
you got me like if you
comment a streamer on this tick tock
video in the next 24 hours then i will
unban them and then i'm like nah i can't
do that i don't work at the company
anymore which is true like i literally
have no idea what happened to dr
disrespect or any survivor worked there
in seven years
it's the biggest conspiracy theory on
the internet ever because everyone knows
the internet can't keep a secret and the
fact that it has been kept kept a secret
is hilarious
um and of course i was just joking with
you
uh obviously you know you don't know but
um
yeah you just i just had to ask uh
finally okay sorry one last question
then we're good i swear
okay one thing i really am curious about
as someone who's been in the trenches of
silicon valley this is a real
like trench question which is we live in
a time now
where it has become the norm for new
startups to get like
copied by the big boys and we have these
market leaders
um that you like google uh amazon
facebook who they see it seems to kind
of be like oh if you make a successful
product
you either get acquired or copied
overnight and so you see that with
clubhouse right where twitter spaces
came out
um you know it seemed like it seemed
like overnight and they may completely
take over the space
looking at that do you think that
discourages
entrepreneurship not talking about that
case specifically because we know it's
happened a million times to a million
different companies of just getting
scooped do you think that's hurting
entrepreneurship and what can
entrepreneurs know
and do to prevent that
well it's definitely
not good for entrepreneurship right like
having huge incumbents that
copy and clone entrepreneurs is not good
for entrepreneurship
i think the best thing you can do the
problem is like the internet economy
in the internet industry is now 30 years
old right and
yeah 25 years old and so
you know there are incumbents that are
very powerful it's like much more mature
and this is it's not unique to the
internet like you know this happens in
every industry so
if you really want to be a startup
that's like not clonable you have to
kind of go
you know skate to where the puck is
going and go somewhere where other
people aren't
and so you know i thought that we were
doing that with justin tv that's a good
example where
we had this company called kiko which is
a web calendar
uh before we started justin tv and kiko
like google google released their
calendar like right after we did right
so
i was like the next company i want to do
something so different that will never
be
in competition with google and so we did
justin tv and we were like okay you know
what it's like me streaming my life to
the internet 24 7.
this cannot be a couple google could not
copy this
yeah criteria right and they're never
going to copy this it's so
insane and then eventually we pivoted
it's funny because we pivoted to
i know you know platform for live gaming
if a platform for live and then pop up
live gaming and then youtube eventually
goes coffee
they add live and then they add all the
same stuff
and they add like the subscription
features they tell yeah
i know man um it is
it is really crazy but now it's giant
versus giant it's like
it's like amazon versus youtube um
anyway yeah thanks for answering that
question because i
it's a question kind of question in the
back of my mind as i look at you know
the modern
entrepreneurship landscape i kind of
feel bad for new founders
or i just think i think it's a new
problem right there are really good
things about having a mature internet
ecosystem they're amazing platforms to
build apps now
to make it so much easier but there's
also downsides and thanks for addressing
that
um i think that's basically it guys
thank you so much for coming on justin
answering these burning questions i hope
people learned a lot
how to be a better entrepreneur don't
fall for the scammers guys
look a lot of great guys like justin
they're not selling a course
listen you can get into white combinator
for free you just have to have a great
idea
thank you so much uh for sharing your
knowledge justin appreciate it
absolutely this is awesome thank you
great go check out his youtube channel
guys
see ya
[Music]